all right man bootleg care podcast we
got a special guest about to do what he
does my guy echo is in here
yeah yeah that's good vegas is in here
who like kevin let's go
i used to weigh tables and hope one day
i'd find a way
the music would pay i just had to be
patient work and wait
the shorter the play the more you get
shot in the footstory lanes i know it's
my time low-key killing it call the tva
had to build my own lane still talk race
when i spit they're so lame i'm building
everything up big with slow games i care
about a grill made black and gold chains
[ __ ] the dolce i still rock vans i don't
touch dirt but still got hands rock like
warped sword a kid got bands with a
brown and blonde hair i still got stains
i don't need a cap and a rapper to you
never started that for the racks and the
jewels maybe because i never thought i'd
actually do what i did and didn't want
to fail so i did it too try to better
build defenses against my own egos
intentions to get green sea levels then
neglected i'm here for the long-haul kid
respected
no tats on my face i don't hate on the
ones who do i just hate on the way that
some people these days use that as the
marketing tool when the label sees
something organic that's killing it
filling up somebody's pockets it's only
a matter of time before they start to
commercialize it just to better their
profits oh no i don't trust no one i
don't like your chumps this justice
league we killing that first try kid no
snyder cut no crypto i just go up my
middle finger don't want to go back down
so i just leave that up for y'all i
don't care at all taking your face and
i'm bashing it until the surgery after
it's leaving you unrecognizable call
that a khloe kardashian i just been
bringing the passion and up on the stage
to look like an evangelist rappers i
hate but they keep me around cause they
need me to bring up their [ __ ]
averages music turn me to a masochist
the modem and building the band with the
paint hearted together with bandages
making a profit of damage just taking
the canvas and painting in blood people
say hey cause i quit all the drugs but
they don't know if they're hanging
around me for enough they'll probably
end up with the buzz
still sick with a beat roll through with
the bearings emo drip jimmy boo got a
trick up the sleeve hold it down for the
nerds and emo kids apparently you don't
care about the skill it's more battle of
the cloud you've gotten likes i just
write on a rap how i feel watch my [ __ ]
double overnight trouble when i write
man i live a life that you wish you
could barely sleep at night cause i live
a dream i don't wanna miss any second
here i ain't even rich i ain't even cool
i'm not even big never had a flap never
had a hit never had to change anything i
did and i'm doing well keep on hating
[ __ ] hey y'all are some soccer moms i
am they deals and octagons you're not an
artist if you can't make [ __ ] without
having a trend to be hopping on setting
the target and locking on heart of a
lion but i am a wolf and i'm hunting
down every one that you calling to go
just to show you how wrong you are hey i
might be a wild guy shameless like i
came from the south side tell me that i
need to raise the bar i'm going met them
in a red man [ __ ] tell me how high any
point in the verse all sound bite my
career health plan no downside when i
step under the stage crowd hype trying
to make it in the game no down time
don't even trip if i don't make it in
this rap i just dip do like these other
white rabbits and flip genres and blow
up by singing and [ __ ] that ain't a diss
that's just a threat if i don't get
loved then i'll take the respect if i
don't get either i'm taking the check
the ceiling's too small i'm not staying
in jet
yeah that was amazing echo dog
appreciate you man tell hey yo tell
everybody your instagram you know hit me
at echo music it's ek oh music that's on
every platform go get it go get it man
album out right now appreciate you man
that was crazy